[Music]
right out of the gate movie is a dick to
people with epilepsy also why are there
metal detectors outside the school
splurge on weather resistant metal
detectors or is this just some idiotic
plot device to make Shawn look like more
of a badass when it actually just makes
him look like he favors large belt
buckles how was the fucking mascot kid
able to fit through the metal detector
in the first place and why does he
already have all in the mascot costume
did he wear it at home and then drive to
school with his gun this teacher writes
some masks on the mark of a word and
then walks over to this other marker
board and simply it's Monday on it then
goes back to the map also this is the
most complicated series of instructions
for 8 x equals 72 I've ever seen I mean
X is 9 goddammit it's that simple and
she not only writes the same equation
down twice for some reason but she's
also making solving for x the most
confusing thing ever
who since one for the racist Indian
mascot and a second one for the racist
Indian pinata so it's come to this the
Fast & Furious franchise unable to get
Paul Walker Vin Diesel and others to
come back for a third movie rated home
improvement 4 star 7 years after that
show went off the air Sean goes to a
fancy school where they offer slo-mo car
repair as an elective giving him an
unfair advantage to star in this
franchise if they aren't painting him
purple to make him look like grimace
then this is a terrible waste of
bullying this movie was written this
asshole football player carries around a
spare baseball just in case Lucas black
from Slingblade talks to his girlfriend
and needs to smash his window with it
also this kid certainly has one hell of
an arm he's able to completely bust
through the rear windshield of this car
just by throwing a baseball also also
also the ball went through the rear
windshield passed through a wormhole
that exists in the back seat then came
out behind the car this movie took great
pains to show us that Shawn had put the
wrench back in the toolbox so what is
this supposed to be
it's either the dumbest misdirection in
the movies first five minutes ever or
it's a continuity error either way it's
sinful as winner gets
me mean sexy and all but also the movie
thinks it can avoid the women are prized
to be one criticism by having this girl
volunteer herself as the prize no one's
working in this large development during
a weekday either this subdivision really
feels the effects of the housing market
crash two years before it actually
happened or the symbol this truck that
is not part of the race is able to keep
up with two cars that are custom built
to go fast
back in 2006 there were many issues
people faced every day and we dealt with
them the best we could but two movies
cars and the Fast and Furious 3 made
clear that many Americans suffered from
the embarrassing inability to drift
these movies need to explain how when
Sean was way behind he caught up in a
matter of seconds but now that he's
caught up and on a completely different
Road he can't pass the guy he's so
easily caught up to this prompts clay to
do the thing he should have done ten
minutes ago drive faster than the other
guy Sean bust through a framed house
with little to no damage to his car
because his car only sustains damage
when it's convenient to the plot they
survive this and Sean survives all this
this seems like an awkward time for a
Tabasco product placement movie wait a
minute who was in position to record
this when Sean did his stunts there was
no one around with a camera only one set
of parents show up for clay and Cindy
which makes me think that they're
brother and sister so now I'm in some
kind of Flowers in the Attic subplot
that's way more interesting than Sean
moving to Tokyo and learning how to
drive sideways so where are we moving
this time why does everyone seem to
think you can avoid being prosecuted for
a crime by moving to a different city
this kid broke several laws they can
move on they want but he'll still have
to go to before a judge in the town
where he committed the crimes in case
you confused it with Tokyo french guiana
sean is upset that his single adult dad
has a woman over because if Sean isn't
getting laid then no one should get laid
but your mom she said the 7c we're a day
ahead of you in Japan which would mean
it's the eighth in Japan which would
mean the seventh came and went and you
weren't at all concerned that your son
didn't show up at the airport yeah but
which train how does he get to the
station which one is his stop doesn't
need to make transfers can I read the
signs to be able to buy a ticket so many
questions left by this note Sean makes
it to school without getting lost ish ah
no one is even slightly concerned that
Sean speaks basically no Japanese and is
still expected to be successful at a
Japanese high school Sean grimaces at
what looks delicious
did he already forget what American
school lunches look like you sell on
Sparco Stan well the steering wheel
isn't inside his bag because writing
meaningful dialogue that would reveal
their mutual interest in cars would be
way too much work Twiggy's ride is an
Incredible Hulk themed Volkswagen
minivan
because he thinks the name of this
franchise is the function and the
spaciousness from when you blow your wad
man everyone loves semen jokes this
large group of car enthusiasts somehow
has the ability to take over this entire
parking garage at night convenient cute
girl we saw at school earlier who also
shows up to the late-night street races
is convenient Nilo right here quick
Elena being able to recall one person's
name is hardly indicative of learning
speed I see that's funny because I
thought this was like a free country is
this guy supposed to be our protagonist
because he's really been nothing but a
dick the whole new day if you saw this
dude from any other characters
perspective you'd understand why
everyone else is a dick back to it you
know who I am my you like the Justin
Timberlake of Japan hi man this movie
can't even get its insult right future
sex love sounds was a mere three months
away and it took the piss right out of
this insult in record time
the Mafia this is really Twinkies fault
for not briefing Shawn on the potential
gang activity in this parking garage the
other one that's not kids evidence
unless race didn't we see the entire
last 13 minutes of this movie in the
first 12 minutes is this like Groundhog
Day and no one told me take mine this is
the worst decision this guy will make
today wanna see what the kids got and I
have gobs of disposable income an
insanely good car insurance so I don't
care if he beats the out of my car you
know a DK stands for King dream Shawn
who is a car and racing enthusiast
doesn't know what drifting is forcing
the movie to explain it to him and me
and you you know that real famous
painting the one and a woman who smiling
on the Mona Lisa come on you're telling
me this dude didn't know what the Mona
Lisa was called I mean for Christ's sake
pick something different for him to be
ignorant about this car right here's
like the Mona Lisa a drift worth and
even though Shawn has never drifted
before they still let him drive it this
guy is eating out of a magical Mary
Poppins bag of croutons that never runs
out it's literally insane that Shawn
doesn't kill anyone during this race
with his lack of drift knowledge and all
by the way how is Shawn even close right
now this guy is drifting all over his
ass and Shawn crashed like twice but
here he is making it some kind of a race
it's amazing this movie wasn't more
successful it took something really cool
racing and made it look like someone
aggressively trying to find a parking
spot Shawn decides to keep racing
instead of stopping and saying you know
what you've clearly won this round
because I don't know how to do this so
I'm gonna go and learn how to drift
during a five minute montage and we'll
try again next week if an asshole drifts
up a spiral ramp and no one can see him
is he still an asshole the answer is yes
Shawn loses the race and wrecks Hans car
which is exactly the kind of Purple
Reign or eight my own kind of conflict
this movie needs will he ever learn to
after win respect watch those other two
movies to find out human race and shine
don't lie to me I can smell it on your
breath this isn't a game if you're gonna
live under my roof you're gonna go by my
rules
oh man movie just unlock the secret
cliche prize box tell them what they've
won Jeremy thanks Jeremy Moody you have
won an additional ten sins for all the
cliches in this movie there's a guy in
there with the paw that owes me some
money how hard would it be to say this
guy is a paw tattoo on his shoulder han
decides to be needlessly cryptic to
create this unsatisfying reveal han is
making a convincing case to change the
Apple asshole sin to nondescript bag of
snacks basically working the same magic
here movie continues the tradition of
this franchise putting its cars on roads
where there is no traffic I call you
show only if you teach me how to drift
the Senate negotiation how was it
negotiated okay so I'd be happy to teach
you how to drift in my spare time that
as long as it's not a negotiation
what's your language context clues and
tonal inflection all suggested I am
totally down with the drift lessons geez
let me state for the record that Sung
Kang is the most aural actor in history
really stop following me around
neela is attracted to show on for
several reasons but mostly because the
screenwriter told to let me guess your
moves around a lot
why do all these army kids go to regular
Japanese high school isn't there a
special army kid english-speaking school
they can all attend and why are you
letting me race is your DK's kryptonite
why though he's been here for maybe a
week and all he's done is severely
underperforming one goddamn race can do
better than 180 can it can catch you
they ever find out they can bring in
other cop cars to block them off or use
helicopters to track speeders they'll be
unstoppable movie totally thinks it's
the Good Fellas of drift movies ok cars
are great and all but I have trouble
believing that a heterosexual 18 year
old dude can take his eyes off two
beautiful women who are giving him
attention to go look at some cars
crashing this dude's car was the best
thing Shawn could ever do in his life
why is this asshole being taught to
drift on a dock are there no empty
parking lots where you can practice
leash
did they want him to stop the fight why
don't they just grab a teacher I would
like to pause in the middle of this
fight to tell you why we're fighting in
the first place
you know in case any students / film
goers don't know what this is about spit
fisting so how'd you end up over here
anyway well you know there's old
westerns the Cowboys make a run for the
border it's my Mexico oh also Han
continues to be insanely cryptic because
creating an identifiable backstory for
this character would be way too
challenging and would get in the way of
all the establishing shots of brightly
colored cars and pretty girls it's a
trust and character I need around me you
choose to be around you but you know who
you are or who you're forcing to be with
you because he wrecked your car and you
need him to pay off the debt that to one
car in exchange for knowing what a man's
made oh that's a price I can live with
so having Shawn wreck your car proves to
you that he's reckless cocky and
possibly stupid I guess those are all
the qualities of character he's looking
for so if you don't drift away in what
do you joyful holy Sh this movie is a
stone's throw from Disney's brink
[Music]
you know you can also say hello to meet
women that also works also drift
seduction also how many tires do you go
through per day to keep up a drifting
habit
[Music]
all of that just to get a number sorry
setup is required for simple digits than
count me out of the dating pool and
drift world first dress to his advantage
drifting out you in the mounds my
feeling they lived in a terrible feudal
society where they had to drift for
their leashes in order to keep their
lands also Han leaves out all the
crucial technique needed to actually
drift but yeah just feel it and see how
that goes again does he mean repeat this
shot again because we've seen it three
times the guys learn so much when are we
ever gonna stop fishing and get married
this movie expects me to believe that
Shawn was able to learn drifting at an
expert level in a matter of months and
is able to beat these guys that have
been doing it for presumably several
years this guy needs to take a drift
management class I realize now outsider
an insider doesn't really matter all the
matters knowing what you really want
going after and serendipitously crashing
some stranger's car who happens to take
you under his wing helps to also Shawn
knows what he wants he wants to win a
drifting race just for the sake of
winning one synchronize drifting we see
come up here little kids even before we
could drive we cut class sneak out come
up here what's the only kids drift so
before you could drive you used to come
up here to the looking mountains to
watch people drift how did that thing
happen did you hike up here
or did you Marty McFly and hitch a ride
on someone's car while on a skateboard
also even while drifting Neela is able
to softly whisper this story to Sean and
Sean seems to understand every word
oh come on man look are you telling me
that Sean saw this dude get out of his
car saw him start walking angrily
towards him and didn't think to run
defend himself or otherwise prepare for
a fight
stay away from although only the Uni
diving is a good jab I'll help you beat
out of him if he promised me a
wheelchair drifting montage do you know
Dean hey I'm starting to think all the
dialogue in this movie was constructed
like a ransom note using screenplay
clippings of other popular movies like
how Shawn made friends with two other
people in high school and the movie
doesn't explain anything about them or
what they have in common
there's enough space for them to just
drive straight away right the drifting
thing is fun and they backed themselves
into a corner by making it the main
reason the movie exists but would it be
way more efficient to just drive
normally even with a good honk warning
you would not be able to clear out a
crowd full of pedestrians and sneak
through some won't hear the honk and
others will be screwed by their fellow
pedestrians and you will kill ten of
them before everything's over chase
scenes with cars like this can be fun
but editing like this is ridiculous
given how fast they're growing I find it
hard to believe they would both be able
to walk away unscathed from this crash
Tom's death scene doesn't include Jason
Statham and yes that's a sin I'm giving
this movie for something that happened
at the end of Fast & Furious 6 franchise
retroactive sinning baby no law
enforcement shows up allowing them to
just walk away and casually get on a
subway DK knew to find them at Shawn's
dance house because he was tipped off by
the screenwriter I wouldn't do that if I
were you
neglectful dad ex machina also how did
he get out here in time did his dad
sense tingle and he knew the commotion
outside was related to Shawn like I left
without a note it's been gone for I
don't know let's say three weeks and now
I'm responsible for my mess I got to do
this can someone explain to me what he
has to do exactly is he gonna kill DK
turn himself into police rescue the girl
convinced bow-wow to add the loo back
and Shawn's vagary somehow convinced his
father to let him go do this I guess
that's one way to do it if you ignore
all the original mistakes he's made all
by himself also was he saying that
Shawn's mess doesn't at least equal or
exceed the mistakes he's made come the
gone all Shawn's dad did was be a bad
father Shawn's going to be wanted on two
continents after this maybe I should
talk to come on I'll let Twinkie take
this one I know I just didn't hit it you
can't just walk into kamata's place man
it's all I got
so Shawn walks right up to kamata's
place gets shot dead and the movie ends
with 23 minutes of credits
something that they ha would
because I mean if you're gonna make it
out of commonness place of life don't
you need it's cool I figured out wait a
minute Twinkie said this is something I
think Han would have wanted you to have
so did Twinkie mean Han would have
wanted you to take my money isn't it
Twinkie who is giving Sean this money
and it has nothing to do with Han
whatsoever the Bailey you can just walk
right up to come out his place who knew
oh no God a mosque the drift training
montage ran long and bumped the learning
Japanese montage I'm here now for you a
peaceful solution is it a race a race EU
movie it costs to cool the cause in
addition to being an unexplained friend
this guy also serves as the narrator
luckily Sean's dad just happens to be
working on a car that could easily be
retrofitted with street racing parts for
this finale to happen this dudes
nickname in the army was God in the
machine is this our third and fourth
montage I lost count
also after Sean requested the race did
he get a full week or so to prepare for
it the accused overlords must have said
I agreed to the race but first get in a
good week to prepare you know what make
it two weeks and here's 50 grand to
start your new business
DK picked his role for a reason this is
his mountain and he's got some barrels
he's gonna throw at you as I see the old
man get out of the car I'm wondering why
did he even agree to this this is a
massive waste of time the stakes are
loser leaves town for good so what he
doesn't get anything from that
arrangement Sean I already gave him the
money han owed if he loses he doesn't
die or learn a lesson or have to give
him more money this is a bullsh
man I was hoping this dude was gonna use
his bra to start the race Kyle watching
this on their cellphones even if there
were invisible drones filming it there's
no way those mid-2000s era cellphones
could play back live streaming video
have you ever tried to stream anything
on edge Network that was the fastest
looking thing at the time I know they're
all about drifting but they could easily
turn around some of these corners
normally and as far as I know you don't
get bonus points for style in this race
nor do you get a little power boost
coming out of the slide like in Mario
Kart 64 it's just whoever gets to the
bottom first all right and here in this
case who's recording this part of the
action there's no one around to
broadcast this but yet everybody looking
at their phone sure seems to see the
race perfectly clear and their tiny ass
screens this camera move illustrates the
cliff that Sean might tumble over if his
car continues to do what this camera
just did which is to confuse us as to
how far away Sean is from this clip I
couldn't really see what was going on
but I definitely smelled some bullshit
it's too bad I don't know how far away
from the finish line these guys are
giving us a course and some updates on
their status might have made this
exciting DK conveniently and impossibly
falls right in front of where Sean is
driving only so this shot can exist
and he survives this party's been being
everybody around Asia - well you heard
wrong because Furious 7 makes you a liar
because Dom didn't come to Asia to beat
a whole bunch of people racing he came
here to pick up Han and yes that's not
only a retroactive sin for a future
movie but that's also a sin we already
mentioned in the Furious 7 video take
that furious let's do it okay I want to
raise setting new huh and why the fuck
does he want to race why can't they just
sit and talk about their dead friends
because we got two minutes left and that
would require a writing dialogue alright
though I got another good time yep
you're just in the middle of all that
Jason Statham book in Furious 7
it can wait Darwin Awards buy ad space
at the end of this movie
[Music]
you know so how'd you end up over here
anyway well you know there's old
westerns the Cowboys make a run for the
border this is my Mexico don't change
the subject just answer the fucking
question
my crazy boy get cool boy got a rocket
in your pocket
[Applause]
[Music]
go
ito yung photonic given you a yoga so
good at a torch image Tom oh are you
carry Varela to avoid a gaudy a my home
it's